the countdown to the Emmys is on
I'm Diddy direct no this is the daily
Deni breaking down everything you guys
need to know about the 70th Primetime
Emmys on Monday night but you know I
can't talk TV without my girl TV queen
herself miss Leanne Aguilar hey guys
they should be here Leanne thank you so
much TVs I'm so excited it's your
biggest night too because guys she
watches Oh literally almost all the
shows you caught up a lot more than me
which is why I needed you here today
exactly and I know there's a lot of TV
fans watching right now so let us know
you guys as we're talking which TV
series which actors you guys are excited
to hopefully maybe take home one of
those trophies and statuettes on Monday
night let us know we want a fan boy a
fan girl out with you
but let's get into it because you know
what this year's Emmys I feel like an
you tell me yeah it feels like an
opportunity for a lot of first-time
winners which is such a big deal because
you know typically Emmy voters once they
find a show or an actor actress that
they like they hold on to that person
looking at you Julia Louie Dreyfus this
is really exciting this could be a year
that a lot of first-time winners take
home that coveted trophy which would be
such an exciting twist and I'm thinking
is specifically about those comedy
newbies yeah you got shows like berry
glow the marvelous mrs. Mable all vying
for comedies top prize get into who we
think will win and who should win
definitely do it
okay so for Outstanding Comedy Series we
have to be talking about Atlanta that
show is just breaking so many amazing
boundaries it is such an exquisite show
that's unlike anything else on TV and
I'm really hoping that it will get the
attention of the Emmy voters because it
really does deserve in my opinion to go
home with the top right and Donald
Glover really took his time to evolve
this second season made it something he
almost made something something
different but still the Atlanta vibe if
it was a limited series anthology see
like the same kind of turn like an
American Horror Story really twisted it
on his head and I thought that was
really great so do you think that's what
should win I think okay you tell me what
you think
well then I'm gonna break it down all
right Kay well I agree with you Atlanta
is one of those buzzy shows and it won
the comedy best excuse me Outstanding
Comedy Series um so this year though I
feel like there's a lot of buzz building
with a marvelous mrs. Mazal on Amazon
right you loved it everybody loved it
throughout the show and of course
because the Golden Globes loves
first-time nominees they loved that
shiny new show Rachel Brosnahan took
home the top prize as well as the series
at the Golden Globes a lot of people
like you are thinking that the marvelous
miss Mayer will take home Outstanding
Comedy Series here's what I'm thinking
might happen
don't tell me I think that Atlanta is
going to win Outstanding Comedy Series
and then they're going to give Lead
Actress in a comedy to Rachel Brosnahan
so that everyone gets a little piece of
the pie surprise yeah dog lover will get
outstanding the comedy actor I think
that he will as well okay but I just
think that Atlanta is gonna get it I
personally think that berry is the best
new show out there it is sensational if
you haven't watched a binge it you won't
regret it
yeah it's great it's a really pack
actually all of these two black a
sensational last season I mentioned glow
the return of Curb Your Enthusiasm
Silicon Valley and unbreakable kimmy
schmitt which have been nominated in the
past - exactly
kind of hard to choose but I'm with you
between Atlanta and marvelous mrs. Mazal
well we've been going back and forth on
what's exciting is that three-time
winner veep is not in this category
anymore so what's really cool is that
somebody else gets a chance to take home
that prize yes so as much as I love me
some veep I'm excited to see someone new
we'll see if someone new can take home
Outstanding Drama Series because talk
about jam-packed I mean you got the
Americans its final season right the
crown yeah it's the last season with
Claire for a taking on the lead of
course as a game of thrones penultimate
season right Handmaid's Tale come on
straight things this is us one of my
favorites world and West world right and
this is us the only Network series in
this category to hold it down for
network this is uh who do you think
should win in this category okay hands
down I think it should be the Americans
this is a show that has proved itself
time and time again but has never really
gotten two Emmys love that it deserves
it wasn't in the last couple seasons
world really started to get some
nominations this is I truly think that
it should be the Americans I don't think
it will be though unfortunately you
mentioned once the Emmy voters in the
television Academy
find a show that they love they kind of
hold on to hold on to this year yes the
Handmaid's Tale hammies til one last
year and even though season two was not
as fuzzy people weren't talking about it
as much I really do feel like that it
still has that momentum that's gonna
propel it forward
I feel like West world took itself out
of the running by having way too
complicated of a second season don't get
that gel they really shot themselves in
the foot Game of Thrones I think that
they're gonna hold out for its final
year let this be the Americans time to
shine like Mad Men right yes like Mad
Men the crown it could be a way for them
to honor it because it's gonna be Matt
Smith and Claire's for his last time
playing those roles but I don't know
keep in mind about Game of Thrones
Thrones guys because I know there's a
lot of die-hard fans out there for Game
of Thrones it will be back next season
before it's last season and even though
it also leads what the most nominations
at 22 so you know they're still gonna be
racking up some trophies oh completely
but not the big one but there's a lot of
momentum going in for G ot
exactly we still have that final season
okay love it okay um another major
category outstanding limited series now
this of course is where last year big
little lies just swept and won it was a
big which is not a limited series
anymore a lot of fans are actually a lot
of TV critics actually we're saying like
so are you gonna give that trophy back
at the time it was eligible for the
cabin no longer but what's the big
little lies this year this year it's
American crime story Versace
the assassinate the assassination of
Gianni Versace on hands and above the
production value on this and just the
high wattage of star power they have
Darren Criss who's crushed it in that
too titular role
Penelope Cruz Edgar Ramirez Ricky Martin
starpower in this is insane it's insane
and and these love being dazzled by the
big stars all those names by the way
nominated this year so we're gonna get
to see you then at the Emmys people like
Penelope Cruz and Ricky Martin who we
know normally don't see at this award
show yeah no Penelope's gonna show up
and address to slay and if she's not
wearing Versace then there's something
wrong like you know Ricky Moore is gonna
show okay um there's a lot of fan love
coming out all right now Belinda sings
she loves Atlanta there Mike yes of
course stranger things for life I
thought was an incredible second season
so great was so so good so I mean at
least it's gotten enough love to and
recognition from the Academy to be
invited to the party
exactly but one of the things that I
think that will keep stranger things
from winning that prize is that there's
not the buzz of the next season coming
up when the voters were voting for this
they knew that the third season of
stranger things wasn't coming out until
summer of 2019 so when you don't have
that momentum of another show coming
it's hard to keep up that buzz yeah yeah
nutria man saying go crown go crown
another solid second season there okay
obviously you guys there are so many
categories at the Emmys we can't break
them all down in fact if you guys want
to see the full list of nominations you
can head over ET online.com but before
you go we do want to highlight some
other races to watch the one the ones
that we're excited ones that we're like
anyone can take this home let's start
with us Outstanding Lead Actress in a
Drama Series no you're telling me this
is a my goodness okay Outstanding Lead
Actress in a Drama Series this is such
an amazing category we have Tatiana
maslany from orphan black for her last
year on the show she of course is a past
winner Claire Foy Elisabeth Moss Sandra
Oh Carrie Russell and Evan Rachel Wood
now I'm personally rooting for Miss Keri
Russell because she was absolutely
sensational in the Americans and I would
like to see her get that last chance too
but if any voters want to make history
they should give it to Sandra Oh because
not only would this be her first Emmy
win of her career ever which isn't
saying cuz she was nominated for five
times on Grey's Anatomy five times if
she wins she's gonna be the first
asian-american woman to take home that
prize which
huge that's our first nomination in this
lead in this leave category for killing
Eve which was fantastic if you guys
haven't watched it it's such an easy
binge BBC America check that out so
splitting it a little bit on who should
win but who do you think will win I I
think it's going to be Elisabeth Moss
know she won last year she has that
prestige she has a claim the show is
being revered as being such a big
movement for females right now
absolutely yeah and that's wonderful but
I really no offense Elisabeth Moss I
really want Sandro to get it or Keri
Russell well because you also want to
spread the Emmy level I got one last
year yeah she's good and if the show
gets one like go home with one and you
mentioned you know what a historical win
that would be for Sandra oh oh there's
actually a lot of diversity in the Emmys
this year I do want to point out because
even in the Lead Actress category for
comedy series yeah you got Tracee Ellis
Ross and Easter a who if they win in
that category will be only the second
time a black woman has took home that
trophy which is absolutely incredible
and Tracee Ellis Ross I'm just gonna go
on a mini blackish Tanja's yeah
completely crushed it in this last year
one of the things that the Emmys loves
to do is to give awards for a comedy
series that is actually way darker like
that's why or just the new black was
reigning supreme for such a long time
but they did an amazing almost divorce
storyline on blackish they got super
dark on that typical comedy and it
really just showed her acting range
along with Anthony Anderson and I just
thought she was sensational so props to
her right now
well sorry yeah props to the chaos of
the nominees and Outstanding Supporting
Actress in a comedy series this is this
is another category to watch because you
got a mix of some em events oh yeah
people who where you have a couple under
their belt also three SNL cast members
and then another batch of first-time mom
and this is a big category this is eight
women vying for this top spot in all
eight of them could easily take this
home because they're also sensational of
those SNL girls that you mentioned we
got eighty Bryant yes same thing with
Leslie Jones and then last year's winner
Kate McKinnon yeah a lot of people are
thinking that it will be Kate McKinnon
again just because they'd love to have
that domino effect don't know that but
also there's no
nine that cake is the star of SNL right
it has been for the past couple seasons
agreed and a lot of camera time too
because your camera you guys they submit
one Episode four other nomination yeah
what's working in SNL's favor it's over
an hour yeah right and keep MacKinnon I
mean she's in so many sketches it's kind
of hard to ignore
exactly and you get to see her in so
many different lights because she has so
many different characters yeah I do
think that Alex Borstein from the
marvelous Miss Mazal is amazing she
actually just took home a creative arts
Emmy last weekend for her voice-over
work on Family Guy so charity has one
but she deserves another and I just want
to note that of course we have Megan
Mullally on Will & Grace always
hilarious Laurie Metcalf was nominated
for Roseanne but I think given all of
the turmoil surrounding that series yeah
that the Emmy voters were like we're not
going to touch it
mhm interesting a note both Laura and
Megan I mean their be nominated for
roles that the originated for their
shows yeah - yeah so I thought that that
was a really nice thing yeah Hartley's
agreeing with us actually she said kate
mckinnon for president okay we're gonna
be talking about the host in just a
little bit but I'm gonna say right now
Kate McKinnon should've been the host of
the Emmys that's true there you know her
pals for SNL co-stars are the hosts we
will get to that yeah Justin but I'm
just saying it should have been her or
the three SNL girls who were nominated
tonight I want a trio oh yeah that would
have been great that'd have been awesome
yeah there's one category that I'm
really excited to watch come Monday and
that's outstanding reality-competition
program which for the last couple years
has gone to NBC's The Voice now this
year there's a lot of momentum and a lot
of buzz over RuPaul's Drag Race they're
saying it could win the big one after
ten seasons you know it's gotten a
RuPaul has won outstanding reality host
the past three years but they're saying
this could be the year for its tenth
season that it can actually take the
best reality which would be amazing
because you know that is a category that
favors consistency yet again because
before it was the voice constantly
winning it was the amazing rates that
always took home the prize so I think
that it's really exciting that RuPaul
who has proven time and time again that
they are the outstanding host this is
the show absolutely become ten seasons
to get on this
of the cultural pop cultural zeitgeist
everybody watch this last it should be
and that's why it should and will win
we're all calling right now
who could be the Dark Horse of that
Caterpie think the dark court I mean
honestly the Dark Horse here is the
voice yeah you know it's fresh off it's
uh this is nominated for its fourteenth
season but now we're in the middle of
season fifteen and they're already cast
a lot but I did love the dynamic in
season four I do think that it's smart
as we're going on a mini voice tangent
that they are shaking up the judge's
chairs we just got a the announcement
the Kelsea Ballerini is gonna be doing
it as well as John Legend for season 16
in the spring yes he'll be replacing
Jennifer Hudson yeah I'm glad they're
shaking it up a little bit because
people little thing but I'm rooting for
room are you guys for all of our
predictions on who should and will win
at the Emmys that's also up on ET online
we've got a lot of should win Oh check
it out I just wanted a fanboy well we do
have a lot more art saying I think that
the comedy leads for female category is
the toughest so good this year yeah
absolutely I agree 100%
I agree are you guys so as you know this
year the Emmys are hosted by SNL's
Michael chain Colin Jost they are of
course the Weekend Update anchors now
this is the first time a duo has hosted
the award show since 1999 when Jenna
Elfman and david Hyde Pierce hosted et
as you can tell right here was at the
official red carpet rollout at the
Microsoft Theatre in Los Angeles and
that's where ETS Kevin Frazier caught up
with Michael and Colin to find out what
they have planned and what's uh in
Storyful come Emmys night
take a look
what kind of will you have changes you
know people wear different outfits from
the carpet to the show so you know after
parties are you gonna rock one look the
whole time I understand that you come
from like the old-school streets of New
York and you know the newsdesk
it's Hollywood now guys is Hollywood
gotta have the Hollywood flavor you have
to embrace and don't eat well you gotta
get your clothes together bro come on
now at least one
I mean honestly honey I already have
that laid out like on the bed
yeah you know I'm hoping to have a lot
more plan that night and I will say hey
maybe they just don't like doing
interviews but I was that was a bit of a
snooze fest honestly like it is the 70th
annual Primetime Emmy Awards it happened
to fall on NBC I think it's great that
they shook things up a little bit by
having to host but I think that they
should have had to female host we saw
how much we loved watching the Golden
Globes and their host by Amy Poehler and
Tina Fey if it had done that the thing
that could be working in their favor
though I will say in their defense is
they could bring whatever writers they
want on for the award show so hopefully
I mean come on we can update everyone
Tunes in for that every week so I'm
hoping that they brought some of those
writers over you know not everyone Tunes
in either so I watch SNL like a lot of
people do now I catch the YouTube links
the next day and I pick and choose the
ones that I want to watch and I'm sorry
I always skip Weekend Update maybe don't
do it for me they just I just for some
reason I'm excited
I hope they prove me wrong I hope so
Emmys on Monday and I feel about the
fact that enemies are on a Monday I do
because I get my weekend I like
I'm ready Monday's great why not I'm
just not ready for the additional
traffic in a lie that's going to be
affected because of Monday night but
it's gonna be a big week I will say it's
gonna be it could be a big night for SNL
too they have 21 nominations going into
Monday so it kind of makes sense that
they asked Michael yeah Michael and
Colin to host they were announced as
host before the nominations came out but
in fact that's true but see it's still a
big night for us nominations and also
guys you know each he will be on the red
carpet here's what we're looking for
we'll call and bring Scarlett Johansson
his girlfriend has a date on the red
carpet we asked him and he said still
trying to figure it out just like their
wardrobe and also will Pete Davidson and
ariana grande hit the Emmys red carpet -
of course Ari has kind of taken low
profile since that we learn about her
ex-boyfriend rapper Mac Miller's death
yeah but we'll definitely be looking out
for that they don't seem like they're
necessary I don't know if you saw at the
VMAs they ran by the rest because they
just don't really seem like red carpet
lovers hmm I feel like they might just
want to like watch it from home that
night watch like that sounds music she
could also be support man in the
audience in the crowd will be looking
for that - guys the Emmys air Monday a
Tom on Monday at 8 p.m. 5 p.m. Pacific
on NBC and of course et will be on the
ground cover and all will be backstage
we'll be at the parties you'll be at the
party maybe at the parties guys so you
can stay up to date on et online.com and
then on Monday right after the Emmys
make sure you join us right back here
for a live recap of the show the biggest
moments are the weirdest moments cuz you
never know it isn't a major award shows
the most awkward moments we're gonna
talk about it all and then on Tuesday a
live fashion recap and everything you
didn't see on TV that will happen
Tuesday at 10:00 a.m. right here thank
you guys and thank you Lee inside we
love TV yeah amazing we love you guys
make sure you guys join us back here on
Monday for the daily Denny and have a
great weekend bye
[Music]